bonjour et bienvenue sur les antennes de
france 24
notre invité aujourd'hui et claude leroy
celui qu'on surnomme le sorcier blond le
sorcier blanc c'est d'ailleurs le titre
de son livre qui est sorti il y a un
petit bout de temps aux éditions arthaud
merci d'être sur notre plateau merci à
vous alors vous avez fait une carrière
professionnelle en france uniquement
après vous êtes devenu une sorte
d'oiseaux migrateurs en asie mais
surtout en afrique à la tête de
nombreuses sélections six sélections
africaines où vous avez disputé neuf
phases finales de coupe d'afrique des
nations alors la coupe d'afrique des
nations on est en plein dans l'édition
2022 elle se tient au cameroun plus au
cameroun voilà un pays avec qui vous
avez remporté la can en 1988
alors la question que tous les
supporters africains mais surtout
camerounais se pose c'est est-ce que
d'après vous le cameroun a des chances
et vraies chances d'aller au bout oui
sont ils sont bien rentrer dans la
compétition de façon solide pas
brillantissime et solide assez efficace
et on sait que c'est dur de gagner au
cameroun c'est arrivé hélas pour eux la
première fois ils ont réalisé pour le
monde la seule coupe d'afrique des
nations sur 72 où il avait été battu en
demi finale par le congo à domicile mais
je pense qu'ils sont ils ont encore
besoin de beaucoup travailler dans le
domaine collectif mais il faut dire que
c'est une vente hinault et ont permis
aux joueurs de d'arrivée que quelques
jours à la fifa que quelques gérants la
compétition absolument invraisemblable
de faire que les entraîneurs n'ont pas
eu du tout le temps de préparation et
que les premiers matchs sont servis
finalement deux matches ou
d'entraînements un match de préparation
puisque c'est pas une phase préparatoire
comme c'est habituellement le cas pour
les coupes d'afrique des nations parce
qu'il y ait beaucoup de pression pour
que cette can ne se tiennent pas il a
tout fait lui c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
que c'était vraiment le ska pas de
l'afrique
exemple jour de l'ouverture mais il
semblerait qu'il était un petit peu
chahuté et sur la justice il a tout fait
pour la coupe d'afrique des nations
n'est pas lieu
sur le continent africain
j'aurais peut-être voulu comme pour
certains de ses preuves
l'envoyé
géographiquement par l'épée dans les
pays du golfe
non c'est moi c'est du dédain du mépris
de l'indifférence base on obéit à des
intérêts chez ceux des clubs dans les
quelques mois il mais il m'est
insupportable parce que j'ai vu
plusieurs fois j'ai rencontré plusieurs
fois quand il est venu en afrique et il
parle jamais de foot il ne parle que de
fric et on a l'impression que c'est un
chef de bureau du fmi à qui il se pare
de capitale en capitale
équipe qui pense qu'il peut jouer que
sur la cupidité des dirigeants africains
alors certains le sont effectivement ça
peut marcher mais sur le long terme il
sera père long mais l'afrique a bien
fait de bien sûr bien sûr alors on va
revenir au terrain quand même il ya une
autre sélection que vous avez entraînés
qui n'a jamais gagné la coupe d'afrique
on en parle comme une des favorites le
sénégal premier tour très poussif mais
ils sont là est ce que c'est la bonne
moi je suis c'est très ambigu c'est
compliqué pour moi parce qu'il
ya deux pays avec elle je suis
effectivement le cadre du sénégal parce
que je dois beaucoup à ces pays je pense
que j'ai gagné avec le cameroun j'aurais
dû gagner cette coupe d'afrique avec le
sénégal je pense que serait cassé le
plafond de verre contre lequel ils
essaient de grimper depuis des décennies
parce qu'on aurait dû on aurait dû en 90
ou en 92 la gagne et je pense que
j'avais le meilleur effectif
des faits de jeu des petites histoires
ont fait qu'à chaque fois on est allé en
demi finale et en quart de finale donc
ça joue beaucoup il ya un blocage
psychologique chez les sénégalais avec
cette coupe il est toujours là il est
toujours là ils ont démarré
difficilement alors qu'ils ont une
équipe n'aime pas une équipe un effectif
assez extraordinaire mais
je pense que plus la compétition va
avancer et plus on va les voir émerger
au plus haut niveau ils ont eu des
pépins aussi avec l'aco vide
des allers retours avec gueye histoire
entre watford l'olympique de marseille
dont il a quitté le groupe il est revenu
donc ça pas été facile pour eux de ce
début de coupe d'afrique alors il ya une
particularité dans cette coupe d'afrique
des nations c'est que deux tiers des
entraîneurs si j'ai bien compté 16 sur
les 24 sont africains se sont même des
nationaux est-ce que ça marque un
changement parce qu'on a souvent vu et
vous en faites partie évidemment les
entraîneurs occidentaux surtout
européens sur les bancs de touche à moi
ça me fait un peu peur ce discours là
parce que on devrait créer une espèce de
clivage entre les nationaux alors qu'est
ce qu'un entraîneur national
est ce que mes amis qui sont djamel
belmadi aliou cissé en traduire de
l'algérie du seignal 2 pour moi des
trois grands favoris de cette de cette
compétition
sont ils plus africain
que moi qui ai passé beaucoup plus de
temps que sur le continent africain ils
sont nés en france ils ont fait leur
carrière pour les céréales en france ils
ont passé leur diplôme en france alors
c'est vrai qu'ils sont l'un algérien
d'origine et l'autre sénégalais donc moi
je me méfie toujours un petit peu de ces
clivages quelquefois un peu démago qui
sont faits pour dire l'afrique aux
africains j'en parle d'autant plus
facilement que moi tous mes adjoints au
co véritablement locaux sont tous
devenus sélectionneurs après mincir que
partout où je suis passé moi j'ai formé
des sélectionneurs nationaux qui ont
pris en charge les équipes d'aso ado je
pense qu'il faut faire attention de pas
rentrer trop dans ce genre de clivages
c'est bien que par exemple et miradoux
l'entraîneur des comores donc avec toute
sa carrière en france qui était même
entraînement de macadam acteurs en
france et reprise avec l'équipe des
copains parce qu'il fait un travail
extraordinaire tu as fait d'ailleurs un
exploit formidable sortie
devant le ghana vous imaginez un petit
peu les commet et moi je la connais
d'autant mieux cette équipe que celle
qui nous a sortis de cette qualification
avec le togo delà de la coupe de
création quand je disais que c'était une
équipe on devait respecter et que
c'était pas un faire-valoir et qu'on
nous reprochait presse d'avoir été battu
par l'écologie on aurait dû gagner
effectivement mais c'est une équipe de
qualité ils ont fait un véritable
exploit il aurait presque déjà pu être
qualifié à part un but près dans les
dernières minutes dans le deuxième axe
donc non il ya ça travaille bien dans
plein d'endroits et je pense quelle
importance et quelle que soit la
nationalité c'est que les gens vivent
sur place et bosse alors je vais revenir
à votre histoire que vous serez retracé
dans ce livre vous quitter vos fonctions
d'entraîneur à grenoble on est au milieu
des années 80 et là vous devenez
sélectionneur du cameroun presque on
vous a presque tendu un piège les ché je
suis un peu poussé par la sortie par le
patron milliardaire à l'époque marc
braillon équipe qui veut infliger une
amende mes joueurs parce qu'on ait fait
un match nul et mac mais refuse donc
voilà tout de suite le clivage se crêper
demande de quitter et puis le hasard
fait que grâce à albert batteux qui
habitait grenoble et qui est un peu mon
maître ès football et eugène n'jo léa
qui était l'ambassadeur qui a été
ambassadeur au en espagne angleterre qui
est un ancien joueur d'albert battu à
saint-etienne il appelle un jour à la
maison c'est ma femme qui lui répond et
il dit le cameroun voudrait claude
gauvreau ne voulait pas vraiment on
essaie d albert batteux qu'il avait
demandé quel profil albert batteux lui
avait dit je pense que le profil idéal
pour un pays comme le carbone c'est un
jeune entraîneur comme claude jean et il
dit qu'il ya une des plus belles
capitales du monde que c'est un petit
paris - les embouteillages qu'il n'y a
pas de maison à paris ce but contre
brest
c'était pas forcément ça correspondait
pas forcément complètement là à la
réalité et j'arrive au cameroun est
effectivement le ministre alors que j'ai
discuté de rien du tout qu est l actuel
sultan qui vient de décéder à deux mois
le braiment boggia gamme personnage
formidable issa hayatou est le directeur
des sports du ministère annonce devant
flopée de journalistes centaine de
journalistes dans la salle de
conférences que je suis de nouveau
sélectionneur
en gros dés zaghouan ma femme qui
n'était pas au courant comme moi qui a
l'impression que finalement j'ai un peu
travaillé en dise en acceptant un poste
sans lui avoir dit et le ministre après
cette conférence vous écouter et que sa
grande voix sur montreux morges est
obligé de dire ça parce que on est dans
une telle situation est peut-être perdre
4-1 en zambie et et demi de la coupe du
monde c'était compliqué donc je me suis
retrouvé sélectionneur sans jamais avoir
discuter les termes d'un contrat ce que
je n'ai jamais regretté alors vous avez
ensuite eu plein de péripéties vous êtes
recruté notamment par celui qui était
président de la rdc à l'époque joseph
kabila qui lui a cave où il est allé
lui-même vous recruter il a demandé à
son ambassadeur en rdc à paris de
rentrer en contact avec mal
à l'ambassade utilisé d'ailleurs pour
fêter le titre de la tunisie en coupe
d'afrique des nations et du devoir en
dix ans le président voudrait absolument
que vous que vous preniez l'équipe de la
rdc et c'est même lui qui m'a fait
revenir une deuxième fois en rdc ça
s'est très bien passé la première fois
après le clic acte on était beaucoup
plus compliquée et politiques jouent un
rôle direct et parfois trop direct c'est
pour ça que c'est c'est un petit peu un
non sens quand on entend la fifa dire
que c'est que le pouvoir footballistique
et pas les politiques mais c'est une
cantine quand il arrive dans un pays
demandent quoi il demande qu'une chose
c'est rencontrer le chef de l'état pas
le président de la fédération donc les
politiques jouent un rôle pourquoi parce
que à part quelques fédérations
privilégier les autres fédérations n'ont
pas les moyens économiques de louer un
avion pour que l'équipe puisse se
déplacer dans de bonne condition de
réserver des hôtels de payer des billets
d'avion aux étrangers enfin aux joueurs
expatriés qui viennent qui vient de
jouer pour l'équipe nationale donc les
fédérations n'ont pas les moyens donc
bien des annoncé le gouvernement qui est
derrière alors vous avez rencontré aussi
de très grands joueurs giorgio et à qui
est depuis devenu président du liberia
vous avait joué un rôle clé dans son
recrutement par l'as monaco qui a lancé
sa carrière internationale samuel eto'o
on parle de dirigeants lui est passé de
footballeur avec ce footballeur à
président de la fédération quelles
chances du cameroun quelle chance c'est
qu'elle risque aussi qu'elle risque oui
ça casse gueule mais quelle chance parce
que au moins avec sam on sait que il va
pas calculer combien de vies là il va
pouvoir se reconstruire pendant sa
mandature donc il va être complètement
focalisés sur
le développement du football au cameroun
c'est pour ça m'a judy met le paquet sur
la formation des jeunes sur la formation
des éducateurs sur la qualité des
terrains d'entraînement sur matériel
d'entraînement des choses toutes simples
des filets de protection derrière les
buts ça fait gagner une efficacité
terrible dans une séance de frappes au
but plutôt que que le ballon parts dans
un champ de canne à sucre et qu'il
fallait une minute pour le récupérer
donc il faut véritablement aller vers
l'efficacité et puis commencer à
réfléchir havre et à maman dans
l'afrique subsaharienne créer des
championnats professionnels mais
africain avec les réalités africaines
avec une méthodologie africaine pas
vouloir copier ce qui se fait en europe
en amérique du sud en asie mais il ya
des moyens
d'adapter un football professionnel en
afrique ça évitera des des centaines de
gamins de vouloir partir au péril de
leur vie dans des embarcations dans dans
des camions surchargés pour essayer de
rejoindre ce qu'ils pensent ou est
l'eldorado qui est l'europe et ce qui
est souvent très très loin d'être
l'eldorado le leur à merci beaucoup il
ya énormément d'anecdotes pour ceux qui
sont friands d'histoire du football en
afrique mais aussi ailleurs c'est dans
le sorcier blond qui est publié aux
éditions arthaud merci à vous et essayez
aussi à vous d'avoir regardé cet
entretien sur nos antennes
[Musique]